How is 2024 for Pisces?
The Pisces yearly
forecast indicates a year of promising opportunities.
Jupiter's residence in the second house throughout
the year provides financial and family Protection,
enriching relationships through improved communication
and predicting wealth accumulation.
Positive developments from in laws are anticipated
after May 1st.
Jupiter's transition to the 3rd House bolsters
business prospects,
fostering growth
and positive shifts in marital relationships.
Accompanied by potential financial expansion,
dedication to responsibilities notably increases.
However, Saturn's year long presence in the 12th House
warrants financial caution
with potential opportunities for foreign travel.
With Rahu in the 1st House and Ketu in the 7th House,
fluctuations in marital life are indicated.
The conjunction of Rahu and Jupiter until May 1st
emphasizes treating friends well
and avoiding impulsive decisions.
The year's start holds promise
for romantic relationships,
although Mars's influence on the 5th House
might lead to minor challenges.
Vigilance is recommended during the mid year period
when the combined effects of the sun and Mars could
escalate conflicts.
Health concerns might pose challenges
for your loved ones,
with the middle part of the year
generally being favorable.
Career wise,
the year appears optimistic,
with excellence in your job,
positive opinions from superiors,
and potential
opportunities for overseas work assignments
for students.
The year's outset shows promise,
with a focused approach leading to success
despite obstacles.
Family life might present ongoing challenges
requiring a cautious approach.
Health wise,
fluctuations could occur
with eye problems or foot discomfort possible.
Following a healthy diet
and Routine is advised